what's about Brock Meyer I really first
of all idea of this show Hank Azaria it
is a terrific idea Hank Azaria an old
friend of mine from Simpsons days he's
brilliant in this role as a newscaster
for baseball baseball newscast was very
successful sportscaster and then he
melts down while he's doing his job one
day because he finds out his wife's
cheating on it and now it's years later
and if this is this isn't even like mine
it's barely minor leagues ball
yeah he's involved in he is really as
he's down and out and you you workers
yes you own a baseball team and he goes
to work for you and it's a it's a
terrific show so much yeah and you guys
have a really great chemistry together
he comes to work for you you know it's
inevitable and then your two characters
hook up well we're both alcoholics and
we both love baseball and yeah it's a
great match.com no I was gonna say yeah
I just thought it's a really unusual
character for both of us and an unusual
story so I was excited I'm curious
because he's such a funny guy you're a
very funny person when you have you have
these sex scenes and he's being very
finding them are you able to I mean
first well that's gonna be incredibly
awkward but also it must be at the same
time kind of funny like it's just I just
can't be professional as you can
probably imagine my yeah I mean he's so
dear to me and you've been together and
a hundred degree heat for so long and
then all of a sudden he has to pretend
to thrust in between my legs and he's
right here and he's and he's narrating
all of the sex acts staring in my eyes
yeah Meryl Streep I challenge anybody to
be able that's like let's not challenge
melih Streep to that
I believe there's a more worthy
challenge heraldry I bet Hank step
forward Thanks get down here we got a
challenge for you
you